hello i'm michael sheen and i play dr
martin whitley aka
the surgeon hey there i'm bellamy young
and i play jessica whitley
hi i'm halston sage and i play ainsley
whitley
hi i'm tom payne and i play malcolm
bright hi i'm keiko aguina and i play dr
adrisa tanaka
hi i'm aurora parano and i play danny
powell i am frank hearts i play jt
tarmel hi i'm lou diamond phillips and i
play lieutenant gil
and we are the cast of prodigal son here
to play buzzfeed's
who's who
who is most likely to break character
during a take
aurora aurora i'm instinctively drawn to
you holster
i'll take that i have no evidence for
that
to back that up you improv some jokes
we're not breakers no
we're makers not breakers we're sheenies
not meanies
who's most likely to improvise their
lines
me me i like to add in a little humor
when we're talking about murder frank
there's a scene that frank and iron
aurora had i remember what episode it
was
and and you had that line that you said
to wait no you said it to keiko oh i see
you at the end of that scene
oh yeah yeah that was cool who is most
likely to nail a scene on the first take
michael michaels i just can't say
anything it's fine
michael and balmy both of you it's very
tight between everyone
i'm not aware of us doing first dates
and going well that was terrible
who's most likely to pull a prank on set
blue
this is the problem i don't act with
many people in this show
my experience is very limited tom frank
you chase me down the hallways you scare
me you hide behind stuff
that's because it's so easy to wind you
up who's most likely to show up late to
set with a cup of coffee
aurora holston
now it's a bit now it's a bit and now
it's personal
who's most likely to help cover up a
crime
without asking any questions michael
sarah
you're accusing me you are a lawyer you
would help
i don't know if either of you know this
about each other but you've both handed
me weapons
and said can you stash this for me
somewhere no questions
and i said yes i thought we weren't
going to talk about that
i said better because bellamy is like
the nicest person in the entire world
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry you did that
thing but i love you so much and i'll
never tell anybody
just put them in the hole sweetheart
just put them in the hole and cover it
up with dirt
who's most like their on-screen
character frank
me it's ridiculously dry sense of humor
i think yeah you just you know
pop off those one-liners man i i find
you infinitely entertaining
michael can i remind you that i play
a serial killer narcissist
psychopath sociopath my god
i feel good about it again who is least
like their on-screen character
bellamy bellamy oh thanks guys
jessica's always like you know having
some terrible drama queen moment and
being sort of
very breathy and and uh and bellamy's
never like that tell him he's always so
curious
i said i was between keiko and michael
because keiko doesn't walk around like
parroting
knowledge all the time even though i'm
sure she has it but she helped it
knowledge tom i know you do i don't
think you like love dead bodies either i
don't know
and michael's not a serial killer that
we know of who is most likely to escape
an escape room all on their own good
girl
yay we say kkk i put lou in that
category too yeah
oh caico oh yes
100 keiko hands down who's most likely
to start their own true crime podcast
aurora i vote for myself because i'm
obsessed with serial killers
me or lou you are lou and
i could go either way yeah yeah i mean
i've done a lot of research on all this
stuff and i
and i am really interested in it and
obviously through playing this character
as well so i feel like i could
what if you're co-hosts oh yeah you
could do it together
refuse i refuse
i'll let him know
you